on me dit que ben vous avez préparé un
cadeau un chroniqueur ah oui bah en fait
c'est un cadeau au fait pour vous arrive
cette fois ci ça fait plusieurs fois
qu'on fait des mauvaises blagues
lorsqu'on passe au monde votre
gentillesse ce grand coeur tout ça en a
marre alors j'ai enquêté avec vos
équipes et aino boisjoly jeu si vous
habitez est-ce que vous reconnaissez
cette porte à porte là on l'a 20 ouest
c'est pas trés moussa sy mais alors est
aussitôt rentrée alors écoutez on a bien
fait alors d'abord d'abord quand il
ferme soit savès d'abord il ya des
périodes des gens qui vous aiment dans
votre équipe
d'abord eu les clés de chez moi oui et
oui
donc là on va rentrer chez moi
absolument ah oui alors ils vont tomber
alors moi je voulais un possible et
qu'une vraie part j'aime quand les
chéris pcc et du coup si je peux
récupérer un caleçon que j'avais laissé
moi alors les chéris moi je pense en
régie est ce qu'on va vraiment rentrer
chez moi me dit que non allez-y matt
d'aidé zoomer dézoomer plus des zooms et
triste à dire qu'on peut est ce qu'on
peut avoir un plan large si vous allez
voir je sens que c'est pas [ __ ] c'est
toi alors vous vous avez vraiment cru
que vous aviez m'avoir sécher bien sûr
celle
[Applaudissements]
vous avez fait la ferme célébrités
mathieu promener par ici jamas eh bien
chez vous avez ces chenilles ça va puis
et c'est moi pas et là alors on va faire
un petit peu le tour du propriétaire
regarder s'il ya d'autres choses à des
quotidiens continuent d'attiser la
visite chez benjamin castaldi
ça va et que sa venue a fait plaisir de
voir qu'un mail vous savez ce qui peut
ce qui me ce qui me rend fou ouais c'est
que j'envoie à ses coûts pour piéger me
fait [ __ ] à chaque fois eh ben voilà
mais voilà donc c'est chez vous non mais
non mais c'est votre salon m'a jamais
mais alors ça veut dire donc vous savez
c'est bien que ma femme ma batterie nom
et votre femme vole vers vous a trahis
mais vous aime quand même merci à kamel
en tout cas aussi voilà c'était pour
boubacar keita dit
[Musique]
savoir mon badge et puis ça chie par
tous ces trucs là vous à tous et en
céréales du parti mais chez nous on va
rentrer dans le top 30 des souvenirs de
tpm paix et dans un instant on va
retrouver maxime guény maxime galy cas
rendez vous avec l'amour les cherry et
je vous le dis on aura une très très
grosse surprise dans touche pas à mon
poste je vous le dis regardez il ya une
cabine à bluff juste là une magnifique
cabine à bloc pour l'occasion de ses 9
ans ava benjamin pas du tout
[Musique]